we're going to prepare the extraction
plates for the filters automated viral
and bacterial RNA DNA extraction
protocol we will create an extraction
mixture for 100 samples so go ahead and
get a 50 mil centipede tube and add all
of the components for the my plate into
the 50 ml tube
first wool pipette 10 microliters of
proteinase K for every sample
that you need to prepare the extraction
mixture for
then add two microliters of solution L
for each sample you need to prepare the
extraction mixture for
for each sample add 250 microliters of
buffer Nye
to complete the Mye mixture add 500
microliters of isopropanol
per sample
the Mye mixture serves to lice your
sample add 762 microliters of your Mye
mixture to each well of your Mye plate
add 250 microliters of each sample to
your Mye plate
when you're done allow your mie plate to
incubate for 10 minutes before
proceeding
while your Mye plate is incubating
prepare the beads plate by adding 190
microliters of water to each well
then pipette 10 microliters of
the mg pure beads into each well of your
beads plate
ensure that the beads are well mixed by
petting up and down
next prepare the RNA wash plate
the RNA wash buffer must be prepared by
adding 48 milliliters of ethanol to the
bottle before use
add 500 microliters of RNA wash buffer
to the RNA wash plate
prepare the illusion plate by adding 15
microliters of the EPC treated H2O to
each well of the illusion plate
your mie plate should have been
incubated for at least 10 minutes add
the tip comb for the automated
extraction protocol
foreign
select the filters automated extraction
protocol on your construction machine
here we're using a kingfisher Flex
the Kingfisher Flex will prompt you to
add each
plates to the appropriate position on
the carousel hit start after adding each
plate
[Music]